tonight we explore the topic of
transgender athletes in high school
sports it's a difficult balance between
the rights of transgender individuals to
compete and the rights of others to
compete on an equal playing field
here's correspondent Jackie Heinrich
high school runners are going toe to toe
this weekend at the New England regional
championships in Boston a chance to get
in front of college coaches and maybe
even earn a scholarship but Connecticut
juniors Selena sole won't be competing
in the 55 meter dash she was edged out
of the top six spots in part by to
transgender runners Andreia Yearwood and
Terry Miller both male at Birth now
identifying as female Terry said a girls
state indoor record aundrea came in
second it's frustrating and in a way
demoralizing when you're at the start
line of a race and you know what the
outcome of the race is before it even
happens medical physicist Joanna Harper
who's also a transgender runner says
high school athletes like Selena can
face unfair competition from trans girls
it comes down to whether trans athletes
have undergone hormone therapy before
these athletes get on hormones then they
have all of the athletic capabilities of
men but high school athletics aren't
governed by a single set of rules making
regional competitions a gray area
according to trans athlete comm
Connecticut is one of 18 states that
allow transgender athletes to compete
without restrictions seventeen states
review individuals case-by-case and nine
states require surgery or hormone
treatment six states have no policy at
all part of the challenge is age college
students and Olympians must undergo a
year of hormone therapy to compete as
trans athletes but most teens don't
begin hormone therapy until after
puberty civil rights are also a concern
Hudson Taylor is the founder of athlete
ally a non profit LGBTQ athletic
advocacy group any pathway that
separates or divides or segregates trans
athletes into a different category is
separate and is not equal and is not
fair advocates say rules for pro
athletes are one thing but a lot of high
schoolers join teams to have fun and
transgender teens shouldn't be denied
those same positive experiences Shannon
Hori Jackie thank you very much